Is copywriting worth learning in 2025?
That's exactly what I'm going to help
you figure out in this very short video.
Because let's be honest, with AI, claw,
chat, GPT, perplexity, all of these
things that at a click of a button, you
can have entire sales letters, emails,
tweets, all those things written for
you. What is the point of learning this
skill? I'm going to get into that in
just a second. But for all you people
who need all the ton of social proof,
I've been a copywriter for over three
and a half years. I've been in marketing
for over 12 years. I'm a number one
bestselling published author on
marketing. I've made six figures every
year that I've been in copywriting,
including my first year. Have had five
figure royalty checks, five figure
launches. I've built my own email list
to over 5,000 copywriters. Social all
the social proof that you need, right?
All of these things. Okay? So, let's
just get that stuff out of the way and
talk about what you're actually here to
talk about. And that is, is it worth it
for you to dive in? And for me, it is a
resounding yes. It is absolutely worth
learning in 2025, but not for the
reasons that you think I'm going to say,
not because of all the royalty checks
and the career I've built and I'm super
biased and all of these things. Bear
with me for a sec because I'm going to
give you five very simple,
straightforward reasons that I don't
think you're going to expect at all for
why I'm saying you should learn
copywriting in 2025. The number one
reason that you should be learning
copywriting in 2025 is because
copywriting is not about the writing.
Okay? Copywriting is just a written form
of sales. And so what you're actually
learning when you learn copy is
persuasion and human behavior and market
research, offer creation, product
tomarket fit, and all of those things
that come with being an incredible
salesman. And if you didn't know, sales
is the number one highestelling skill in
the world. It is the number one most
profitable skill, okay? Always will be,
always has been. And the reason is
because you directly generate income
with sales. And so whether you actually
want to write or not write, copywriting
is the best way to learn sales because
it encapsulates everything about sales.
The product, the market, the persuasion,
the communication, all of those things
are built into the concepts of learning
the fundamentals of copywriting. So when
you go buy a copywriting book, you're
not learning copywriting, you're
learning sales in written form. So to
understand this skill takes it beyond
just the writing itself. You can
actually go apply these to any job in
the marketplace. Which leads me to
reason number two is you don't have to
be a copywriter. Okay? So a lot of
people don't think copywriting is worth
learning because they don't want to be a
copywriter. You don't have to be a
copywriter. You could take your skills
of copywriting and apply it to whatever
business you either want to build or
serve. Okay? So, you could take all of
those sales concepts, communication
skills, human behavior, market research,
all the things that you learn with
copywriting, and you could build your
own business. You could build a golf
business, and you can make a lot of
money selling golf products, emails,
website, landing page. Perfect. All
because you learn copywriting. Or you
can serve ecom products, supplements,
shoes, whatever. You could sell anything
in the world. So, you don't have to be a
copywriter at all. you'll just know all
the fundamentals to guide those
businesses, whether your own or someone
else's, to grow in income over time.
Reason number three that you should
absolutely learn copyrightiting in 2025
is because writing is still the most
dominant form of communication in human
history and will always be. Think about
it. Text messages, Slack messages,
presentations, website, landing pages,
ads, emails, VSSL, scripts, everything.
Everything is based on writing. and you
read more than you watch videos all day
long. Even if it's subliminary between
all the messages, ads, emails, things
that you read on books, brochures, all
this stuff, written form of
communication is still the strongest and
most dominant form of communication. And
so, copywriting is going to teach you
how to be a much better communicator.
It's going to teach you how to get your
ideas across quickly. It's going to
teach you how to be more persuasive in
your writing. It's going to teach you
how to be clearer in your writing. I run
an agency of over 30 employees and I
could tell you right now that 99.9% of
people even in the marketing industry do
not communicate clearly. They don't
understand how to portray ideas. They
don't understand how to take complex
ideas and make them simple. They don't
understand how to put an idea out there
and make it persuasive for somebody else
to buy into your idea. All of these
things will help you grow not just a
business, but it'll help you grow your
relationship. It'll help you grow
practically anything else that you're
trying to build. All because you are a
better writer. Reason number four that
you want to learn copywriting in 2025 is
because even with AI, you want to
develop a taste for AI. Let's say you
want to use AI to write a bunch of stuff
for you. You want to prompt it. That's
the ease of use. That's the future.
That's the direction. the thing you
still want to have, the skill set that
you still want to have is to be able to
see what that writing is and determine
whether it is good or not good and for
what reason. Okay, this is what most
business owners and 99% of entrepreneurs
get wrong is they take the efficiency,
the ease of use and they say great now
it can do the task for me. But you don't
know whether the task is good or not
good. I apply the same concept to
coding. I am not a coder. I am a
copywriter. At one point, I tried to
code an app, but it had so many errors
that I couldn't actually build the app
because I didn't know what the errors
were. I was dependent on AI to try and
scan and find those errors. And all it
did was create more errors. I, as
someone who is not a coder, had no idea
how to make this app good in the way
that I wanted it to be because I don't
know how to code. And so even though AI
does know how to code, when it did
things wrong or when things were broken,
I had no idea what to look for. The same
applies to copywriting. AI will always
pump out stuff that is not relevant to
your market, that doesn't make any
sense, that's not great storytelling,
whatever it is, doesn't matter how good
it is. And if you don't know how to spot
what's wrong and what could be made
better, then you will always be
equivalent to anybody else who has
access to AI, which is everybody. So,
anybody can pay $20 and then prompt it.
And they are now at the same skill level
as you. You have no edge over anybody
because you don't know the difference
between an AI prompted copy or actual
professional great copy. And if you
don't know the difference, now the
playing field is completely level. You
need an edge. You have to understand
what makes it good and not good. And by
learning the skill yourself, you can
look at it and say, "Boom, I know what's
wrong with that. I can make it better."
Which leads me to point number five is
you need to develop non-dependent
skills. You need a skill that is not
dependent on other people's creations.
Things like AI, social media platforms,
things that other people have created
and control themselves. You need a skill
that has nothing to do with that, but
that can be applied more
generalistically. Human skills,
copywriting being persuasion, human
behavior, market research, and sales all
en wrapped in one is the most dominant
human skill you could ever have in the
world. So you could take any job,
doesn't matter. You could sell boats,
you could sell cars, you could be in
marketing, you could run a car wash. It
doesn't matter because human persuasion,
behavior, market research, all those
things apply to anything you want to do
in life. And it doesn't matter whether
there's a ton of AI, no AI, fang tanks,
it doesn't matter because internally you
have a skill that doesn't need to sit in
front of a computer to prompt to
understand what to do next. You already
know because you've developed yourself,
not a machine. You want to develop
yourself. If your only skill set is
using machines, then when machines no
longer work for you, you are screwed.
Aka, if AI were to go down tomorrow, my
business is fine because I know what to
write. And if I weren't able to write at
all tomorrow, I could get any job in the
world selling anything tomorrow. I have
the most profitable skill set in the
world, and it's incredibly accessible to
you. So for you to not want to learn
that skill set makes zero sense to me.
And for anybody discouraging you not to
learn that skill set also makes zero
sense for me. Again sales number one
skill in the world. Writing number one
form of communication in the world. So
sales writing together is the number one
skill in the world. It will never be
outdated to learn copywriting. And so
I'm encouraging you. Yes, go get some
books off Amazon. In fact, I made a
video of the top 21 books that I highly
recommend for you. You can watch that
down below. Or you can grab my
copywriting catalyst, 63 cash cow
copywriting tips that will make you a
better copywriter practically overnight.
Takes you like 30 minutes to read and
you'll have a ton of copy tips. That's
free in the description below if you
want to click that, put your email in,
and it sends directly to your inbox.
There are tons of resources for you to
learn copyrightiting. It has never been
easier. So, I encourage you, even if
you're not going to be a copywriter, go
pick up this skill immediately. I hope
this video was helpful. And if it was,
please like and subscribe. The video
tells me that you want more copywriting
videos. And make sure to leave a comment
below of what you want me to teach next.
Happy to help. Tell me what videos to
make. I'll make them for you. And until
next time, we'll chat.
You got me.